creo que ahorita es un muy buen momento
para repasar lo que hemos visto hasta
ahorita de cómo financiar una compañía
que está empezando déjame ponerle aquí
arriba financiamiento financiamiento
ya hablamos de dos formas de financiarse
una con capital privado y otra con
capital público dentro del capital
privado estaban los inversionistas ángel
y algunas rondas verdad que se llamaban
seriedad serie b y así sucesivamente
más o menos la idea del capital privado
era la misma en cualquiera de sus etapas
déjame dibujar una hoja de balance que
quede así bien bonita
para que podamos trabajar sobre ella de
este lado teníamos el activo que nos
está dependiendo de la etapa era una
idea talento etcétera y del lado derecho
como no nos hemos financiado con nada de
deuda teníamos el capital que era todo
nuestro vale entonces luego que sucedía
déjame escribirle por aquí que tenemos
cierto efectivo ahí estaba el efectivo
teníamos una oficina oficina así también
teníamos pues a lo mejor una marca
verdad y otras cosas de este lado
teníamos todas aquellas cosas que
llevaban un beneficio futuro para la
empresa del lado derecho el capital
estaba dividido en distintos accionistas
verdad dependiendo de cuántos fuéramos
este aquí estaba dividido en acciones
pero la idea en cada una de las rondas
es que íbamos con el capitalista de
riesgo con el inversionista ángel con
ese con él con el de la seriedad o lo
que sea y le decíamos mira necesitamos
más dinero y entonces ese el
inversionista hacia una evaluación de
nuestro negocio por ejemplo digamos aquí
decía que esto vale un millón de pesos
y luego pues ya nos ofrecía cierto
dinero supongamos que de un millón de
pesos
teníamos un millón de acciones entonces
básicamente el capitalista nos estaba
diciendo que cada una de nuestras
acciones valía da un peso entonces le
voy a poner un peso de precio por acción
y de este modo básicamente nos está
diciendo que está dispuesto a comprarnos
cada acción a un peso entonces si
nosotros le decíamos que queríamos no se
entera me ponerle acá otro rectángulo
voy a poner como por aquí a ver creo que
que es un poco sueco como por acá
si nosotros le decíamos que queríamos
otros 2 millones de pesos entonces aquí
de este lado teníamos que emitir un
capital correspondiente una cantidad de
acciones correspondientes proporcional a
eso como acá un millón de pesos cero
millón de acciones aquí arriba dos
millones de pesos va a tener que
corresponder a dos millones en acciones
entonces esa era la dinámica con esto ya
podíamos trabajar un poco más que
ponerle efectivo ya con este efectivo
podíamos pues hacer anuncios en la final
de fútbol o lo que fuera muy bien ese
era la mecánica y al final de cuentas lo
que acababa pasando es que digamos
después de esta ronda él se quedaba con
dos tercios de la empresa y nosotros con
un tercio pan pero después dijimos chin
a lo mejor necesitamos juntar muchísimo
dinero de una forma muy rápida porque
necesitamos una cierta urgencia para
competir con el mercado actual y
entonces empezamos a platicar de otra
opción que era una oferta pública
primaria oferta pública primaria
y bajar un poquito para ser una hoja de
balance este nueva para que todo quede
más en limpio y acá la idea era pues más
o menos la misma verdad aquí teníamos un
cierto un cierto activo del lado derecho
teníamos un capital que hasta ahorita
sólo ha sido financiado por
inversionistas privados la compañía es
privada a lo mejor has escuchado ese
término de compañía privada y compañía
pública déjame déjame escribir aquí
arriba que aquí arriba era una compañía
compañía compañía privada
privada hasta ahorita es una compañía
privada porque solo nos hemos financiado
con capital privado de personas muy
específicas a las que les ofrecemos en
nuestras acciones una compañía pública
es lo contrario que sus acciones las
puede comprar cualquier persona y de
hecho no hemos acabado de explorar el
mercado de capital privado solo el
capital de riesgo pero ya habrá otros
videos en los cuales platicaremos de eso
bueno acá arriba tenemos una compañía
privada pero acá abajo la idea era que
ya se volviera pública porque para poder
obtener mucho dinero y además para que
nuestros nuestros accionistas privados
pudieran empezar a comprar y vender sus
acciones en el mercado de modo tal que
finalmente rindiera frutos de inversión
y la idea de la oferta pública privada
era muy similar el perdón de la oferta
pública primaria era muy similar a lo de
acá arriba básicamente lo que lo que lo
que se hacía es que teníamos un banco le
voy a poner por acá un banco un banco de
inversión de inversión
versión ese banco de inversión era el
líder de misión líder de emisión
y realizaba ciertos trámites con quien
correspondiera digamos la comisión
nacional bancaria y de valores o con el
banco con el banco de méxico con la
bolsa mexicana de valores para informar
que nosotros queríamos hacer una
compañía pública que queríamos
convertirnos en una compañía pública y
entonces después de esos trámites ya
entrábamos en la en la bolsa mexicana de
valores nos daban un cierto un cierto
código creo que en el vídeo pasado le
puse que era el código era calcetines
así calz y con esto ya podíamos comprar
y vender nuestras acciones así en la
bolsa ya se podían cotizar en la bolsa a
través este pues de ciertos corredores
de bolsa o a través de los clientes
importantes de los bancos de inversión
entonces el banco bueno para determinar
el precio lo que tenía que hacer era una
evaluación de nuestra empresa y no sé
digamos a que ahorita por decir algo
está pues nuestra empresa ya es más o
menos grande está valuada en 10 millones
y es millones y entonces el banco dice
esto vale 10 millones ahorita tienes
vamos a suponer que tenemos un millón de
acciones básicamente lo que estamos
diciendo es que el precio por acción es
de 10 pesos 10 pesos y ya bueno con este
precio por acción nosotros tenemos que
decir que tantas acciones estamos
dispuestos a emitir para ver qué tanto
dinero podemos obtener entonces digamos
si si estuviéramos dispuestos a emitir
otros 5 millones de acciones déjame
ponerle por acá 5 millones
y algo de este estilo aquí le voy a
poner 5 millones entonces pues como
estamos emitiendo 5 millones de acciones
y cada una está valuada en 10 pesos
podríamos aumentar nuestro efectivo en 5
por efe no es las herramientas de
rectángulo podríamos aumentar nuestro
capital en 5 millones por 10 ó 150
millones quiero voy a poner tampoco esta
es la herramienta 50 millones 50
millones excelente aquí ya tenemos
efectivo y podríamos hacer un montón de
cosas con esto verdad podríamos diseñar
nuevos productos y lo que sea ahora esto
de ponerle el precio a la acción o
básicamente de ponerle el precio a la
compañía antes de cualquier oferta de
dinero de la preevaluación pues es más o
menos un arte y no te creas que es tan
sencillo osea mira lo que tiene que
hacer el banco de inversión es pues
encontrar más o menos un balance entre
el precio que tiene que dar porque
número uno no quiere que sea abajo
porque la compañía si se merece cierto
efectivo correspondiente actos que tan
capaces de generar riqueza
entonces por un lado no queremos que sea
muy bajo pero por otro tampoco queremos
que sea muy alto porque eso podría
número uno causar que no se vendan las
acciones y número dos podría generar
este este fenómeno del cual platicamos
en el vídeo pasado aquí voy a poner la
gráfica este de acá es el tiempo y este
acá es precio para poner y así entonces
si el banco empieza muy alto y el
mercado dice no sabes que el precio está
muy alto esto va a bajar entonces esto
va a ser malo porque va a dar la
impresión de que esta empresa pues no es
tan buena como ellos creían y pues va a
ser como un cierto estigma voy a poner
aquí estigma
de esta oferta pública primaria
entonces no queremos que suceda esto más
bien lo que queremos es que la gráfica
se vea así hacia arriba bueno entonces
esto de ponerle el precio es más o menos
un arte ya después platicaremos más
acerca de cómo se hace básicamente hay
que fijarse en ciertos indicadores como
retorno sobre la inversión ahorita te
platico un poquito de zona más déjame
pasar por un último punto que quiero
mencionar porque el rayo se haría una
oferta pública bueno ósea ya sabemos por
parte de la empresa porque se haría y
por qué se haría por parte del banco de
inversión por sus comisiones pero por
qué la gente compraría acciones entonces
déjame ponerle por aquí la pregunta por
qué comprar acciones
y hay básicamente tres respuestas o sea
número uno es porque las acciones pueden
subir pero si crees o sea si tú
simplemente compras una acción en una
oferta pública primaria porque crees que
va a pasar de 20 a 30 en un par de
semanas entonces simplemente estás
especulando especulando y eso no es una
costumbre muy saludable en esto de las
finanzas hay una mejor razón para
realizar esta compra de acciones y pues
en el fondo tiene que ver con realmente
que representan esas acciones o sea así
si tenemos cosas del lado derecho de la
hoja de balance es porque le
corresponden activos en el lado
izquierdo aquí es activo y aquí es
capital y esos activos son beneficios
futuros para ti entonces pues no sé por
ejemplo un beneficio futuro que te puede
dar una acción cuando a la compañía le
empiece a ir bien para generar más
efectivo y tener un flujo positivo
entonces un beneficio es que la empresa
te empiece a pagar dividendos esto
quiere decir que tenga más
las
acciones generen
flujo
de efectivas
entonces si la empresa empieza a generar
riqueza te corresponde una parte por ser
accionista y tú vas con tu papelito de
calcetines y te pagan por ese dinero y
finalmente hay una tercera razón por la
cual convendría tener estas acciones que
es un beneficio futuro que podríamos
tener y es que se venda la empresa se
venda o sea puede ser que una empresa
muy grandote vea a esta de calcetines y
diga wow esta tiene justo la tecnología
que me faltaba la voy a comprar
ahorita vale 60 millones pero yo la
quiero comprar en 200 millones
entonces belleza super bien verdad se
cumplen 200 millones y todos estos
accionistas reciben pues un muy buen
beneficio por las acciones que tienen
bueno hasta se sabe eso de ahí son las
acciones y la razón por la cual la gente
quiere tenerlas pero después vamos a
platicar un poquito de cómo poner este
precio de acá como te comentaba es más o
menos un arte porque hay muchos factores
que deben influir como retorno sobre la
la el retorno sobre la inversión como el
ebitda y otras cosas que después vamos a
platicar pero al final al final de
cuentas así al final del día
y finalmente el precio de una cosa es
porque cantidad en el mercado está
dispuesto a comprar esta empresa bueno
hasta la próxima